african nations have a growing problem
countries across the continent
are facing attacks by islamist inspired
insurgencies
the so-called islamic state may have
lost influence
in syria and iraq but it's now claiming
vast territory across
africa expanding and strengthening its
influence together
with affiliated armed groups i'll be
talking to a security analyst in a
moment but first
here's a look at northern nigeria where
two foes
are battling for a common cause
violent rivals now joining forces
this footage purports to show boko haram
fighters
pledging allegiance to the islamic state
and west africa province
if genuine it would herald a disturbing
development for nigerian security forces
we have now joined with
after some mistakes that has occurred in
between us
and we are now together so we are at
central island we should
not relent in our effort to fight the
kuffar
for years the two militias have been
fighting each other
that came to a head last month when
notorious boko haram leader
abu bakr shakao seen here in 2018
reportedly killed himself in a battle
with is
fighters
its feud fears that the so-called
islamic state is consolidating control
of the insurgency in northeastern
nigeria
that's at the heart of a string of
conflicts involving various extremist
groups from mauritania
to chad now there are warnings is
activity is growing in the horn of
africa and northern mozambique too
they came as the global coalition
against is met in rome to discuss the
resurfacing of the terror group
sometimes called daesh
today we began of course with the
meeting of the coalition to defeat uh
isis uh and what we have to do to
eradicate what's left of the terrorist
group
and very critically as italy has been
emphasizing
to prevent its emergence uh in places
like
like africa the italian foreign minister
wants to sharpen the focus on the
continent
i proposed a working group dedicated to
africa
which could identify and stop dies
related terrorist threats on the
continent
at the end of the first in-person
meeting in two years
the global coalition added three new
african countries
to their ranks
and these propaganda images of former
foes burying the hatchet in nigeria
only serve to underline the urgency of
the situation
well joining me to discuss this from
london is bulama bukhari
senior africa analyst at the tony blair
institute for global change
he's also a columnist for the daily
trust a nigerian newspaper
great to have you with us on dw news
africa blama thank you for being with us
thank you for having me rahila now our
report touches on the growing presence
of the so-called islamic state
in africa but i'd like to get your
thoughts on how widespread
their operations are how are they
growing geographically and able to
conduct these attacks
i mean unfortunately isis is so
widespread today in africa that you can
say it is across the continent now
and you are not talking about countries
you are talking about groups of
countries
in each of the sub-regions and when you
start for example with the lectured
region
you have a border written bringing
together nigeria niger cameroon and chad
where the isis affiliate called islamic
state west africa province operates
in the sahel the islamic state in
greater sahara is active and
it is it's hope and it operates in
mali niger and burkina faso and is
becoming a serious threat now to
coastal west african countries like togo
ivory coast and ghana
and then when you go to southern africa
it is mostly active in the northern part
of mozambique and now threatening zambia
and tanzania and also has
another affiliate in the democratic
republic of congo
so it is pretty widespread and
unfortunately the
the the the model is robust it is not
isis sending fighters from iraq or syria
it is isis recruiting groups that are
locally entrenched
but have been fighting in that region
for long
and know the area very well now how
effective will this
international task force b to counter
this threat
and what would this look like in
practical terms
it depends on how it is rolled out if it
is rolled out in the right way
which is uh i mean in my opinion locally
led
then it is uh likely to be um
to be effective the first priority
should be containing the violence
containing the violence requires
massive locally led sustained onslaught
on the group that is led by local troops
but that is logistically and technically
supported by western countries
i think what africa requires expansion
in the lectured region
is not massive western troops presence
it
is local troops but supported by their
western counterparts in terms of
logistic and technical support but also
in terms of capacity building
now these insurgencies are driven by a
number of grievances
you know from humanitarian crises and
poverty as well as the social and
economic grievances as well
could you just expand on that and
explain how is
is exploiting uh these grievances
yeah as i said the security effort is
necessary
but it can only contain the violence it
is insufficient
what you need to do is to tackle the
root causes and the root causes
include poverty and unemployment lack of
education or very low education in many
parts of africa
but also this ability of isis or the
affiliates on the ground to exploit
religion
and local grievances and so you need
massive investment in education
investment in the economy in
infrastructure
but also i mean effort by
local religious and community leaders to
counter
the narrative and reduce the appeal of
these groups
these are the vulnerabilities that isis
exploits of course there are other
vulnerabilities like
porous borders like i mean vast and
governed spaces in many parts of africa
that's why isis got attracted to the
area
about five six years ago and the
international community and local
governments lag behind unfortunately
west africa has all the vulnerabilities
that made afghanistan a hotbed for
terrorism
now i'll be addressing the african
governments and why their armies have
not been able to get this
issue under control what do they need to
do to
address better governance and tackle
issues like poverty
local populations are dissatisfied with
how governments are
delivering democracy has not worked for
populations
in that part of the country and it is
high time that it has started delivering
and so governments must invest in
education
in infrastructure in the economy and try
to strengthen the relationship between
the government and the government
so that for that extremist groups will
not be able to exploit
uh social economic grievances to recruit
young people into violence all right
palama bukhari thank you very much for
your time and analysis
thank you very much for having me in
nigeria schools
churches and villages have long been
targeted by the armed group boko haram
now one catholic priest is trying to
help a community by building a school
clinic and a mosque in a muslim majority
area
dw's fred muvuni traveled to the village
of pagada
outside the capital abuja
[Applause]
every sunday christians gather to
worship in this church
then they pray for their nation nigeria
they ask god for peace and harmony
but this priest has been doing more than
just praying
he's building a bridge between muslims
and christians
through his actions he helped raise
funds to build a mosque
in our climate that is very divisive
a lot of hatred religious intolerance
bigotry we have shown through this
singular act
that we can work together that we as
christians and as muslims
we are all children of god
experts say religious intolerance is the
main cause of tensions
between christians and muslims thousands
have been killed in
interfaith violence in recent years
father charistus issa says president
muhammadu buhari's administration
has failed nigerians and religious
conflicts
have only been exabated by poverty
or lack of resources the support of the
church
towards this predominantly muslim
community
is seen by many nigerians as a unifying
factor
between muslims and christians
the mosque was completed in mail this
year
built by muslims and paid for with money
raised by father charistus
local people from the muslim community
can worship here
for decades the village of pagada never
had
anything like this so it means a great
deal to them
i will not tarnish the image of your
religion and nor will you tarnish
muslims and christians have welcomed the
support extended by the catholic church
glory be to god of course we are happy
i didn't see anything wrong by christian
building a mosque
or a school to muslim because we are all
created by god for father christians
the work to be with the torah and
society is working in progress
the essence is to show that we can live
together
we can walk together we are children of
god
and religion is not for hatred but to
show love
but that love must be nurtured he says
and he hopes every single nigerian can
do their part
rebuilding a united nation free of
conflict
you